The tsunami claimed almost 300,000 human lives.
Yet in all the parts of Thailand, Sri Lanka and other areas destroyed by the tsunami,...
...not a single animal that was free to move lost its life.
Was it the approaching tidal wave they sensed...
...or did they feel the sea quake two hours before,...
...with its epicenter hundreds of kilometers away in Indonesia?
How did they do it?
Is it simply instinct or are there physical or even chemical stimuli they respond to?
Phuket island, South Thailand: the tsunami hit the island's western coast at 10 AM.
An earthquake had cracked open the seabed of Indonesia's Sumatra island two hours before.
But as early as 7 AM,...
...something out of the ordinary was happening on the roof of Phuket's Orchid Hotel.
Yes, I heard some noise from the dog on the rooftop.
They put a dog there.
It ran around, I heard it.
And then I was sitting here, heard the earthquake at eight o'clock or something.